hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger
[Musique]
dt sur ma journée tu n'as pas vu en
toile s'immiscer tt sur mal toute la
sainte journée
si seulement j'avais plus il est en
ligne
ça ne fait pas peur encore et lorsque
les ai pas donné la peine
[Musique]
tous
voilà où ça mais
avec l'euro
[Musique]
il y en a
savoir bien défini dans la norme des
colts comme notamment récupère a réussi
la saisir mais tes cheveux ne menace est
vraiment mais chez nous fait chier
cinéma de style ici c'est votre problème
mais c'est impensable
je nourris le petit personnel
[Musique]
à
et à
hama
[Musique]
l'eau
avec voilà on se filme quand on est
content pour travailler voilà qui
capture les voilà c'est ce qu'ils
veulent
voilà le mythe
[Musique]